all right looking good outside we did
have those clouds and
showers this morning but we knew they
wouldn't last and now we're back to the
clear skies as you
saw there and david's live shot 68
degrees our high for the day today
not much of a difference from yesterday
we were at 70. so we were down just a
couple degrees we knew that we wouldn't
cool down too much
this is where we should be 62 degrees
for our average high let's get to some
neighborhoods now shall we
we started off in centennial hill 66 for
you that includes sky canyon 61
currently for summerlin downtown north
las vegas coming at 70 even
and aliante at 66 71 sunrise manor green
valley
and whitney ranch at 69 henderson 67
rhodes ranch and mountains edge you're
both
also at 67 degrees mid-60s for you and
perhaps
69 up there in northeast clark from
mesquite and same goes for mesquite
death valley coming in at 78 and mild at
this hour here's our doppler network now
sweeping around we had those showers
early they were brief there was just a
narrow band of moisture and was out of
here now all that has moved off
into arizona now we have the clear skies
outside right now but that's not gonna
last because you can see the clouds
already encroaching
into california and the northwestern
part of our state we'll see those clouds
overnight into tomorrow shower chances
will also be out there but the big story
tomorrow going to be the winds
there's your shower chances for tomorrow
just about a 20 to 25
chance and that's going to be after 2
p.m and between 8 p.m and it's just a
light light chance and then after that
look at that valentine's day looking
good
however the wind forecast for tomorrow
does go up later on in the afternoon it
will be breezy midday
but the bigger winds come in the
afternoon and certainly the evening
hours
for tomorrow for your saturday as those
winds will come from the north we'll see
those gusts possibly up to 40 to 45
in some spots tonight 48 degrees
increasing clouds
west breezes but nothing too strong like
tomorrow
chilly and drier overnight your high
tomorrow 64 degrees the winds like we
talked about the windy conditions come
later with those slight shower chances
there are your gusts that we're
anticipating for tomorrow
even higher up on the mountain so if
you're planning to go on the mountain
keep in mind
we'll have some very strong wind gusts
especially later on in the day
a few showers and snow showers are
possible 47 degrees will be our high up
there on the mountain league canyon
canyon eight day forecast does show
temperatures will cool off a little bit
we'll bring back the wind again on
tuesday and wednesday take a look at
that
but plenty of sunshine later on the week
for next week
that's your most accurate weather update
brian bakery